how's it going reject nation we're here
to watch this trailer
call reminiscence what is it don't know
what it is i have no idea what it is but
i'm sure
it's an interesting one warner brothers
hbo max
hug jackman rebecca ferguson greatest
showman
reunion is what i'm expecting here we've
been waiting for
let's get into action and see what's
going on today
with this trailer i hope it's good i
hope it leaves a good
memory in our noggin that we can
reminisce
over okay all right everything's finally
set right let's do
you're this on a journey a journey
through memory
all you have to do is follow my voice
we're closed i know i'm sorry it's late
it's time for one more job oh do you
know
[Music]
oh
[Music]
x-men origins wolverines yeah
whoa
huh
uh
would it be a huge acme trailer without
him yelling
yelling intensely for his lost loved one
whoa
damn rebecca ferguson god
oh dang
this movie looks gnarly
you're going on a journey all you have
to do is follow my voice
cool cool now we finally know what all
those
mystery destruction shots were in that
hbo promo from all those months back
oh yeah that's right those are godzilla
and i was like they gotta be well i was
wrong
yeah man cause you don't know movies not
at all
[Music]
yo that looked like a rad sandwich of a
time right there yeah man
all kinds of elements in there matrix
vibes inception
vibes the fountain vibes yeah
um you got this like cool
neo-noir but also film the war femme
fatale
quality infused with this
crazy dystopian almost young adult novel
aesthetic
to it wow there's a there's a lot going
on
in this trailer and then you got this
personal
journey of a dude living in the past
memories trying to find his lost love
always trying to find that lost flame
you know what though that uh uh my mind
trailed off for like
five seconds and watching this trailer
specifically about hugh jackman
because it's so interesting to me
how we know hugh jackman's australian
and every time he shows up in a movie
he's american
and there's not even a thought of he's
doing an american accent you know what i
mean
yeah every other actor you become aware
that they're doing an accident
but hugh jackman is just someone we've
we expect him to be australian when we
see him in our interview
we expect him to be american when we see
him in a movie i know he's done movies
where he's had like
a southern accent or an australian
accent i know he's he's used his own
accent before
uh i just think that's kind of a random
rare
thing i feel like any other actor you
know johnny depp was doing british for a
long time
we're like cut it out angelina jolie
same thing come on man
come on hugh jackman
you don't even notice it's just so solid
that yeah
he's just an honorary american and it
would be foreign to us
and a film environment that's not called
australia by bazlerman to hear him use
that accent
because you got hugh jackman the really
charming
flamboyant-esque personnel yeah and then
you have
um american action drama leader
you're jacking from my wife you check
man you don't even question it
yeah man that's a testament i really
don't know i'm even watching the
prisoners hugh jackman right here you
know
that that version of him uh yeah i know
has nothing really to do with the movie
that's just
my mind honestly what not just one
second he's gonna be reminiscing about
the days when he could just use his
natural accent and not have to worry
about it
no never gonna happen don't let it
happen
one day you will be you'll have the mel
gibson trajectory where your accent will
have
left you and you will be american
because you have done it for so long
but i do love the tone and atmosphere of
this trailer quite a bit
uh i i i this is the co-creator of
westworld and one of the main
uh for sure one of the main directors of
it and
tandy newnan who is in westworld i see
brought over here i i'm kind of
concerned though
one of the elements of it is
uh i i like a good heady sci-fi movie
and i and i don't know if it's gonna
fully
commit to both you know what i'm i don't
know if it'll
be able to be like your hollywood
sci-fi blockbuster or
could it be like a full-on heady sci-fi
film
it looks like it wants to be both yes
exactly
and you know 90 percent of the time i
can tell when a movie's
like annihilation or something or at
astra
like i could tell this is a heady sci-fi
movie that they're trying to make it to
like a hollywood blockbuster trailer
but i'm like i know what it really is
though and i'm like but with this
trailer
i'm not 100 sure what it is even though
everything looks cool
but yeah they're trying to sell this
blockbuster like it's headier than it
actually is or something like that
yeah you know i want it it's going to be
one of those movies that's going to try
to have its cake and eat it too
um but as it stands you know like i was
honestly i was kind of expecting a batch
rather for some not known reason i was
like it's probably going to be a crappy
trailer
and then watching it i was into it
that's pretty into it yeah absolutely i
mean rebecca ferguson man
yeah you can you can see why he's going
to spend the rest of his life in this
apocalypse hunting her down because it's
hard to beat rebecca ferguson man
that's the perfect j-word is a little
over convoluted though
well yeah i mean it i get what you mean
with the whole like why a thing because
it's like okay it's the future and all
the the sea levels have risen and there
was a war
and and like that's one thing and then
we also have this almost ready
player one esque like everyone then got
addicted to going into the past and
living memories and i'm like does
everyone have one of these water
chambers that you're laying down
yeah um but yeah and then you have like
this abandoned city and you've got what
looks like a very personal story about
this one guy
searching for this woman across you know
hell in high water but then you also
have whatever
chaos seems to be going on in you know
the
main society which i couldn't tell if
that's like a clip they showed from
the prologue or something when hugh
jackman's explaining to us how the world
got this way
or if there's gonna be some kind of like
outside stakes that's gonna turn it into
an action movie to offset the stuff
where he's like my wife
oh yeah i mean it seems like the plot of
the movie is
that rebecca ferguson has a mysterious
past
and uh he she's presumed dead or
something
and so you know he uses this machine to
live in the memories with her because
reality sucks at this point
so what he's going to have to do is
journey across the subway waters or
whatever that thing is called
into uh you know criminal bill yeah and
have to monopolist
and then perhaps discover that uh his
his former lady is not as
nice of a woman as he once thought she
was
um it's gone girl that's for the strange
days a little bit it's got a bit of that
femme fatale vibe
which uh was it was a pleasant quality
you don't often associate with
usually femme fatell's like that weird
michael keaton
movie that's coming yeah yeah
the one with the cool bad ass chick the
one that's not nikita
yeah or lucy yeah that's usually the
fact that
we get but this had like a bit of an
erotic
thriller angle to it yeah yeah yeah
which i don't know would be nice if it
if it really does infuse those
flavors throughout because i feel like
we don't get that many erotic thrillers
anymore
no we need them gone are the days of
sexy michael douglas and hugh jackman
doesn't age so he's perfect for these i
know and he yells like a real
protective warrior that guy he does
we all deserve to have hugh jackman yell
like that on our behalf at least once in
this life
just to know the feeling all right guys
well what did you think of reminiscence
leave your
thoughts down below for this trailer
subscribe
click that notification bell say hi to
hugh jackman for us
and um yeah we'll catch you guys on the
flippity flip
peace